today i had the pleasure of speaking
again with jeremy corbell
a fellow documentary filmmaker who
specializes in the phenomenon of what he
calls
the extraordinary that is ufos aliens
etc this was a live ama conducted on
june 23
2021 and i'm extremely grateful that he
spent as much time with me
as he did especially given the
deliverable amount of work he must be
under
and stress just prior to the june report
if there are other people that you'd
like me to speak to
such as george knapp or chris mellon or
if the star is a lion then bob lazar as
well
please if there's some way connect me my
twitter is
at toe with kurt again it's listed here
in the description
for those new to this channel my name is
kurt j mungle i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
who's interested in the explication of
what's called theories of
everything that is from a theoretical
physics perspective but also from a
philosophical perspective
even from a psychological perspective
perhaps even from the perspective of
consciousness that is
if consciousness has anything to do with
the fundamental laws of nature the
sponsor for today's podcast is algo i
recommend you visit them at algo.com
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software
with software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stockouts reduce
returns and inventory write-downs while
reducing inventory investment
it's a supply chain ai that drives smart
roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of the podcast almost from its
inception
if you'd like to hear more conversations
like this then please do consider
supporting
directly at patreon.com literally every
dollar helps so whether you want to give
ten dollars
fifty cents one dollar nothing even i'm
grateful for that i'm grateful for your
views
please go to patreon.com or you can
donate via paypal or crypto whatever you
like
the plan is to have more conversations
like this with the same intensity the
same
this conversation wasn't terribly
technical but
generally the conversations are at a
technical level i would like to keep
them like that and that requires
often weeks of preparation before i
speak to a certain guest
for example soon i'm speaking to chris
langan who has a cognitive theoretic
model of the universe
he's someone who's known for having the
highest iq in america and his theory
is let's say it's it's not trivial at
least thank you so much
and enjoy oh man
this is just a very exciting time
i mean it really is this is like about a
lot is about to happen
and look you know with me you've
probably noticed uh you know people
are impassioned
so what you'll get is a lot of people
asking questions that really they're
just trying to
you know kind of dehumanize the
messenger me
so they can right right yeah yeah and
it's like no look look the truth is the
truth man
let's talk about it like how did i get
these videos no i don't work for a
government agency
let's talk about that let's clarify for
everybody with that said you got a
beautiful pink background
one of my favorite colors that's 333
degrees i love it
let's do it let's do it man thank you
and you can see me okay with the light
and all that
i can see you fine okay for the people
watching
if you're able to see this type in super
saiyan
so i know that you're watching this
stream
the first question comes from flotilla
has jeremy ever seen a picture or a
video of
an e.t like an alien let's say that you
thought was real
wow jump right into it um
i couldn't say
how do you know if you're not there man
was there one that was especially
convincing that gave you the moment that
joaquin phoenix had in signs
no i'm not gonna you know i can't the
the way i work the way i operate
so everybody hey everybody hello we're
live okay so
listen um you know kurt's been really
thoughtful asked me to do this
ama totally happy to do it uh
unfortunately i don't have all the
answers you know
i i i can't stand behind something that
i haven't
personally investigated vetted and had
my hands on so
with that said i i there is evidence
that there are other beings
engaging humanity you know hopefully one
day
we'll get more information on that very
soon
but no i can't personally say that i've
seen something that i can stand behind
if someone wants to know has your beard
seen anything
it's a great question the mystery that's
what my wife calls my beard because you
never know what food or drink i have in
it
um you know look uh thank you for the
humor i need that
i'm exhausted this has been ever since
you know
april 8th when i dropped the first
pentagon confirmed ufo video
you know look i'm trying to survive i'm
trying to do my job which is to
represent the information that i put
forward i'm tired my beard doesn't see
anything i don't see so no unfortunately
how are you doing these days with your
health and your sleep
you know two weeks no it's great but as
i think we talked about last time weird
question you asked me
uh you know i've got a kind of weird
sleep pattern so
i'm just like there's so much output i'm
sick of hearing my own voice
a lot's going on in the world everybody
pay attention
okay the next question comes from
gonzalez chavez on a recent podcast with
george knapp
both of them hinted that there's more to
come with the bob lazar story
is this true first of all and can you
ask him if he can give us any more hints
this is true the you know
what bob told you in 1989
on may 15th when he told george knapp um
it's true and i don't want to
try to convince anybody of that you know
i think the
the evidence will speak for itself as we
move forward yeah we're going to be
hearing more
all roads will lead to bob lazar that
that should be something
that you know to be true intuitively
with what we're hearing
because as you know now our government
is studying ufos
and that's just been proven it's always
been true it's just been proven so yeah
there's more coming
with bob lazar i really do believe that
uh all roads lead to what he told you on
may 15
1989 through george what do you mean by
all worlds would lead to there meaning
that the ufo topic
remember what bob lazar told you he told
you that the united states military
was studying extraterrestrial
spaceship that they were trying to
exploit those technologies and reverse
engineer them
so now we're kind of getting to a point
where we have to look at what he said
with a little bit of a different angle
now so i i do believe
that that all roads will lead to what he
told you in 1989
all right the next question comes from
amjad hussein do you believe that
there are structures in the deep sea or
deep within the earth
relative to this phenomenon well it
it is established that there is a high
amount
of uso activity so like we have
ufo activity in the skies
the concept of a trans medium vehicle
and what's going on under the water
that's very well established
i don't think it's common knowledge or
common understanding but i think that's
it's going to become more
common knowledge i you know look people
take my words
out of context and then they they
popularize one part of it and so you
might have heard me
say in some tabloid they said you know
like there's an embassy
underwater and what i meant by that is
that
if you're you're visiting a foreign land
and and you're going to be operating
in that location you know planet earth
that that maybe there is a a place
that it's kind of like a way station a
place where people go
and they you know prepare to do outings
and so this is kind of
if the ufo reality is what we
think it is collectively right if an
element of it are ships you know
technology from other worlds if that is
true
then it would make sense you would have
places to congregate
fuel up i mean i don't know and then go
from there i don't know about inside the
i don't know what inside the earth means
i don't know what that means but i can
definitely say
you know within our deep oceans there is
significant evidence
to suggest that there are
i guess resources and structures where
craft would
uh go to dock and then move out from
there if that's true great i mean i
don't know i haven't been under the
water i'm scared of sharks you know so
look can i just say something kurt yeah
man i you know
i i think science is slowly approaching
this like abyss of the ufo reality
and they're kind of peeking over the
edge and and it's cool to see like deep
thinkers kind of grapple with this
emergent reality
that we call the ufo presence i know
that
it's going to come into fashion that we
look at the ufo
problem which means you know a mystery
that we want to solve
and and people are going to say you know
okay great there are ufos they're not us
technology these are probably
unmanned you know probes
looking at our earth that is going to
come
back into fashion because that was in
fashion in the 1960s when congress
got got involved with this topic
i think that's the easiest hypothesis to
believe
for a lot of people's minds but clearly
these are not just like probes from
another world
um you know to like map our landscape or
something like that
we send one probe up to the moon and
we've completely
and to mars let's say and we can
completely map the topography
you know um that doesn't take a lot
that theory excludes the bulk of the
observational
ufo history over time and it maintains
this
presumption that like of the distance
dilemma
right so it says oh maybe there's a
probe there's been so
much contact too much contact
there's something bigger going on so so
clearly this distance dilemma the idea
of
nothing can travel faster than the speed
of light we now know that to be
incorrect so this idea that it's
difficult to get from world to world
you know within our galaxy let's say uh
that is representative of a data poor
understanding of the evidence the
evidence suggests
gravitational propulsion systems the
nature of a gravitational propulsion
system
eliminates and eradicates the distance
dilemma and i really want to nail that
home
because people say oh the universe it's
probably filled with people
people have had the chance of developing
their technology far beyond what we've
had just because they've had more
time on their planets or whatever it is
the distance dilemma is an absolute
sham it is hubris by our scientific
communities to say just because we don't
know something we're going to fill in
the blank so
i kind of wanted to start this off with
you saying look
we're going to move into a new
understanding we are it's there's no
going back
we are people are going to fill in the
voids
with nonsense so we need to get out of
our own way
and look at the evidence which has been
there
the evidence has been there
for decades so now it's time that that
we change
our tonality we eliminate the ridicule
and the stigma and we start looking at
this and i'm sure you'll appreciate it
from a scientific perspective just
wanted to tell you that before we go
yeah
speaking of the scientific perspective
i'm wondering if there are any other
podcasters or youtube channels that you
find to be
trustworthy above board with regard to
studying this phenomena from a
scientific perspective
you know it's difficult for me to say
i'm a investigative filmmaker i'm not a
scientist i i don't
know i just think that
we need to look at it without
superimposing our own
bias or ideas i'm gonna get over a
hundred emails an hour
where it's not only people are showing
me evidence
uh you know obviously i've been
releasing it but they've been telling me
their theories you know what i mean
and and i i don't know i don't know
i just know that we need to look at it
without superimposing our bias
on the ufo phenomenon the ufo mystery
okay let me get to some of these
audience questions
says ask him why chris mellon said bob
lazar was lying about his actual job
saying that his actual job was scanning
radiation badges on workers
right i think that was on the joe rogan
podcast um so
chris mellon had bad intelligence you
know he was
told a rumor accepted it maybe as on
face value
that has later been remedied where he
sees that what he was told
was already completely dismissed by the
man they said said it
to to be very clear to your audience
there were all these rumors about robert
bigelow
and if babazar went into business with
him and what bob's
job was and they're all getting it
through these same sources
but then like bob bigelow went on uh
you know footage on camera with george
knapp and
and completely dismissed these 30 years
of rumors
that he didn't believe bob or bob tried
to lie to him
so people just don't know and i don't
blame them i don't blame them
so so chris mellon had the same maybe
bad intelligence that other people had
that is uh it was it was not standing on
a substantial foundation of knowledge
and understanding
and again you can't blame people for
this it takes time i think joe rogan
probably ended up
educating chris mellon about that uh
no problem look we we all see only kind
of what we can see
and again it doesn't matter to me if you
believe bob lazor it doesn't matter to
bob if you believe him uh i think that
we should consider
what he said though based on reality of
of what he actually said
and not by these rumors and mythologies
that are made up about things he never
said
so look it's a learning curve the lazar
story is so
dynamic it's really hard to get to the
truth because there's been so much
noise and attacks on him over 30 years
so bottom line is i think he was um
ill-informed and had a data poor
perspective when it came to that but i
think that over time
i think that like everybody he'll start
to see that uh
there's more to it than has been said
great a0174 asks does jeremy have any
inside information from the pentagon or
any other government official that he
cannot share at this time
if yes when can you share it
well of course i mean of course
you you see what i'm doing is i'm trying
to
to put out information in a responsible
way
that is digested properly that doesn't
burn sources
look my um number one goal is to learn
myself i'm going to be honest with you
it's selfish i
i want to learn i i put out information
because i at that point i stand behind
it i have
a lot of evidence either non-public and
public
and and i'm just i'm just going to keep
moving forward as strongly as possible
of course i have information that i
haven't put out yet
when can you expect it the moment i can
put it out i'm not holding stuff back
i'm trying to vet information i i will
tell you something really weird though
which is that through my work and
through my sources
i have been able to provide the pentagon
with information they didn't have that
they should have had
so what that means is we have a broken
system so when sources come to me
and it's like there there might be
retribution because the way they
acquired in the acquisition process of
certain types of footage i need to try
to make everybody smoke a peace pipe and
get to the table and say
let's get this out it's non-classified
so it kind of works both ways you know
the government
is not omniscient it's not this entity
that knows
everything right so the answer is of
course yes
and of course i'm gonna get it out and
as fast as i can and be patient with me
i'm one person and i'm doing my best to
vet it and make sure i don't make a
mistake
everybody wants me to make a mistake
right now you know i get emails
i call them love letters but they're not
love you know i get emails every day
just people trying to discourage me i'm
i'm over it
i'm moving forward i'm going to get
everything out to the best of my ability
and hopefully i don't make a mistake
jeremy let's linger on that so what are
some other reasons why
footage isn't released all at once why
the slow drip because
from the perspective of an outsider they
would see you as guilty of the same
sins of omission that we accuse the
government of why don't you just release
this footage you have it
that's what are some so one reason is
source vetting the next one
is yeah sure so
if people could walk a mile in other
people's shoes
you know i think it would change the way
that people
perceive each other and i think that's
so important
um so the primary thing
is source vetting i need to make sure
that what i put out is accurate
there are people that would like to trip
me up i mean not even just
civilians you know there are people that
would like to
allow me to make some big mistakes so it
doesn't matter where
information comes from i need to vet the
sources
second i need to make sure that things
don't
tie back to sources that would harm them
people have
lives man they're taking a risk by
talking with me because we have a broken
system
there are so many checks and balances
that i need to go through
in order to finally put something out
and say i am confident with this
i know the arguments that are going to
come my way i know the vitriol
i know what people are gonna do but i
need to be sure that i'm
one accurate two not going to harm a
source
and three there's this element where we
have to move
into knowledge building on the past
so dropping like a leak like snowden
where everything comes out
like that was chaos that was
chaos and that can cause damage so
there i i am being morally and ethically
i'm being as responsible as i can be
and the thing is it's a living mechanism
what's happening in my life right now
every day i'm getting new information
and just i can imagine
that information is difficult in the
all-consuming
barrage of contacts and information and
messages i mean it's i'm one human
being have patience with me
i'm grateful that you're spending some
time with me man during this
hurricane thank you okay a couple other
people want to just say thanks
schoolcraft donated
16 just just to say thanks and then
talk to me that's great support that's
great so kurt someone gave me 60 bucks
people like kurt mann they're they're
they're trying to put information
forward right like he was relentless
you know emailing my editor like you
know let's do this again let's do it
again
you know it's great when people support
people like you where you're doing
something now to be clear i'm not
getting
anything out of this pocket i just want
to give the information that i have
but i'm glad people are supporting you
thank you so much
i appreciate that man okay something
that bothers me about this
the ufo community i'm not a it's a
strange because i'm not a
part of it i'm investigating this
phenomenon yeah from a fresh perspective
but what i dislike is the fractionation
within it where people
have such caustic remarks about people
if you
consider someone to be believable or
credible or not credible so for example
if you trust louis elisondo
then they'll critique you but then if
you don't they'll also dislike you
i'm not saying that any of this has been
directed at me actually i'm lucky that i
escaped this
because i'm somewhat of an observer
either way okay i want to get your
opinion on two people having said that
what's your opinion do you think luis
elisando is a
credible source and then do you also
think stephen greer is a credible
servant okay so so first of all now
we're doing
exactly what you said you didn't like
which is the idea that you're
you're you know kind of creating remarks
about other people i think everybody
should make their own
decisions on that um however i have
never been shy
of saying my opinion i just don't waste
time dogging other people
right right i'm not asking you to
criticize that i just want to know the
what i don't
it's fine to say that you don't trust
someone but what's not fine is to say
i'm not going to listen to you anymore
because you say that you trust or don't
trust them
i that's too that's too deep for me i
i'm so tired i don't even know what that
means but
check it out man check it out um in my
experience
i have seen so far that lou elizondo
has everything he has said
has been accurate so
i like the guy like he's a nice guy but
but also
just look at what he's told you and
what's been true
so so i kind of feel like he's earned
our trust
and i think that's so important that
everybody make up their own
determination on that
so so in my position it's like
if somebody tells you something and it's
accurate and true
and they continuously do that then you
can predict what they're going to do in
the future
which is usually the accurate and true
so yeah with lou
um i see him to be a great asset to the
ufo community
and i think uh it is good for people to
be skeptical and to ask questions
but but no vitro like none of this um
attacks on character and that sort of
thing
now i'm not going to go so the other
person you mentioned they shouldn't even
be mentioned in the same sentence
like it is so abundantly obvious and
should be
self-evident that that other person you
mentioned
has an agenda and has been shown to be
disingenuous
over and over and over and over again
so i'm going to leave that to the public
to make their own decision because
there's such an emotional tie
to the ufo topic right so i really
encourage
people to to don't like
you know [ __ ] on other people don't go
in there and just make
you know angry assumptions don't make
assumptions at all
ask questions but certain things should
become
self-evident one of those things is i
think uh luella zondo
has appeared to be a stand-up guy and
and somebody that has uh
you know not uh lied to the public in
any way and i think that that means he's
been telling the truth to the public
so you know if it goes on that
trajectory that's great i you know i
think i admire him i think he's great
um and then other people have just taken
advantage
of the true desire of the public and
that's the best way i can answer the
question
where i'm not contributing to the
negativity that i receive on a daily
basis i respect that man
that was a wonderfully given answer
mental director eight 8295 says please
ask where the picture of the stunningly
detailed black triangle
is from rising up in the water and where
is it with regard to release and
release to the public right so this is
an assumed image and
until that image is placed out into the
public
the question is uh where did it come
from how is it captured
it's based on a rumor you know i've been
exposed
to a lot of information and
i would be very curious to see if that
piece of information
uh comes forward because again it's
it's based on on a on a rumor in a way
everything i put out it's it's a you
know direct from source
even if it's through me it's like
right so i'm just saying there are high
fidelity
absolute high fidelity images with
absolute clarity
that and video that has been taken by
our government
over decades of the ufo phenomena
so not even just like radar data but
like high
fidelity images and video
now because of the way these things are
captured
there is an obstacle there like how do
you make that public
how do you scrub certain elements of the
image to make sure the public can see
them
and also is there a desire to allow the
public to see him
we're not even there yet we're they're
still an uphill battle
the only reason you're seeing the senate
intelligence committee demanding
from our intelligence agencies that we
have a report of
some sort about the ufo topic and to
start eliminating things like u.s black
projects
is because representative government
is actually working here based on the
public pressure of
human desire from people like yourself
people like me journalists the
curious people that are allowed on ufo
twitter that's why all of this is
happening
so we've got to keep pushing forward i
don't know what individual piece of
information might be
revealed soon i do know
though that that evidence exists and
it's time to let it out
speaking of journalist david bates who
you can find on twitter at
david b writer wants to know the ufology
communities
is literally decades ahead of the
general public and most of the
mainstream media in terms of information
history documentation
given that the government has literally
said ufos are real
and we seem to be heading to a tipping
point what do you see as the most
productive role for mainstream
journalists
in terms of helping citizens get caught
up without freaking them out or
overwhelming them
sub question given that they most
journalists
lack sources in the military or area 51
or people like what
stories and reporting should be done to
help break the case open
check it out mainstream media
journalists
everybody's coming out like they just
invented the idea of oh wow
ufos there we have the evidence now
we've had the evidence for a long time
we now have corroborative evidence so
it's not just like
a fighter pilot saying they saw
something and being
afraid they're going to say that but we
have radar data
we have electro-optic data such as
thermal we have
night vision we have uh corroborative
sensor data even beyond that such as
satellite
all of that all of that paints a picture
of of a new
reality that that includes ufos
so the best thing
that journalists can do my advice to
journalists and my advice
to everybody interested in this get
caught up dive
deep start separating
the nonsense from what we know
listen to people that have a good
track record of giving you accurate
information
such as george knapp for 30 years look
at my track record
tell me does the weight of my words hold
more
value than people with other agendas
tell me you know pay attention get
caught up
start making noise
okay this question comes from ali reza
ahmed
var the cia started the cia studied
remote viewing and also aliens
some accounts of alien encounters
involved telepathic communication like
jacques valet
investigated isn't reasonable that the
method of contact should be via remote
viewing
every weapon in our arsenal i mean i'm
not going to discount
one method of investigation i think i
think truth is perceived in fragments
and from different angles of vision and
i think it takes a
whole army of curious people
to apply their skills to investigating
the unexplained what whatever's going on
anybody that tells you they know what's
going on
they're they're probably uh they're
probably
not accurate because it's such a dynamic
uh thing that we're talking about we're
talking about the nature of reality
we're talking about other advanced
civilizations
interacting with human beings we're
talking about it being
durational over decades if not centuries
if not millennia since at least the
beginning of recorded human history
definitely since uh the wright brothers
took into the sky
but before that so i wouldn't discount
any method of data collection i would
just use them all
and then try to sort it out i hope that
answers her question
sure it was a guy but his question yeah
do you have any
thoughts as to the connection between
ufos and bigfoot this one's for me
oh i that's outside of the scope of my
investigatory understanding i i don't
know i
um i i do know that
some auxiliary mysteries such as like
you know this idea that there's
some bipedal animal
you know that has been able to kind of
hide from humanity that is smart like
and then they also the idea of like
cattle mutilations those seem so
outlandish and they're so
out there but there's great evidence you
know for the cattle mutilations like
there's
physical hardcore bodies so
the reason those things are often
associated with the ufo phenomenon
is because that's what witnesses report
and they don't have to report that it's
that historically they have reported
that
so i can't exclude that there's a
connection between those things but i
don't know enough about those things
to give an intelligent answer it's not
my wheelhouse
the last time we spoke i believe i asked
you some questions on skinwalker but i
don't
recall what the question was nor what
your answer was but it doesn't matter
within this one year time or eight month
time since we last spoke
what's new in skinwalker because there
seems to be
at least over there this incongruous
juxtaposition between bigfoot
other elements and ufos and so on yeah i
again i i don't know i'm not actively
investigating skinwalker i was kind of
working with george knapp
who had investigated the ranch you know
for like 20 years
and then we went and got the first
footage out of there we got the
government programs we got some footage
that was
you know released in that fashion so
what's going on now
um you you'd have to ask brandon fugo i
mean he's the owner of skinwalker ranch
and so he could probably tell you what
what's going on now
i will tell you though from my i'm going
to be speaking with some
witnesses today in the uintah basin
up in that area the phenomenon continues
to perform as if it wants an audience
you know by the local community it's
happening
all around over there they call it a hot
spot for ufos and associated phenomenon
and remember that's why the defense
intelligence agency
had the program to study the ranch the
ranch was a living laboratory
it's not that all phenomenon happen on
the ranch because they care
where the fence line is that the
phenomenon is occurring
in that area in an uptick of of
experience
for decades and i don't know why but
it is happening so you know even later
today i'm i'm
doing more investigation into that this
question comes from dirt flyer live
right now please ask jeremy if he can
give any more information about why the
fbi raided bob lazar's business during
the making of
your documentary now i know that there's
some controversy around that i don't
know
specifically what something involving
his wife something involving stallion
apparently no
no no not his wife okay so so hold on
so much [ __ ] like let's just stop it
right just stop it like leave the guy
alone with this [ __ ]
so here's the deal man um
think about it this way when i told
people
that this happened they said you're a
liar it didn't happen
you you hired trucks you hired you know
actors and you made it up for your film
okay great when they realized that it
did happen
then it's oh okay well everything else
you said about it
it's not true you know okay
and then when they realized that we got
reports that showed that they were
observing us for two days
and that you know there it was a
multi-agency raid
then it's like well everything else you
said then is not i mean
it's it's it's become to me absolutely
ridiculous that i don't even entertain
the these um theories anymore i i was
there
i was there the day before they they
raided his business
when i left intentionally because they
had been watching us for two days and
that we got documents for that
okay great so so what do they want okay
make up fill in the blank whatever you
want to say all i know
is that i was there the day before there
were employees there during it
it was obvious to everybody what they
wanted to know
and and again in my film i'm telling the
truth
i mean it doesn't matter if you believe
me um our that was the only time in my
life where my private communications
were recorded
and or that i know of and uh
look it happened and we're gonna learn
more about it
um at this time that's where we're
ending it
and uh you know bob lazar has been on
the brunt
of not even the government only but
the ufo public and i can understand why
he doesn't want to talk about it doesn't
want to be contacted why he's a private
guy i'm really grateful
that he let me uh that's my doggy uh you
know he let me tell his story
you know to the point that i did and
there's more coming
but um you're gonna need to decide for
yourself
and not have somebody tell you what does
the evidence
suggest what does it suggest if you look
at the entirety of the story
his account what does the evidence
suggest
you need to answer that for yourself
do you have any speculation as to the
connection like why are cattle
mutilations occurring
are they trying to study the cows i
spoke to kevin knuth who had an
interesting
i don't know if you saw that but he had
an interesting answer with regard to
that
anybody can make up an opinion is that
opinion right
i don't know i just know it's happening
i know that there
are surgical mutilations that are done
here's the biggest point about cattle
mutilations the biggest point
there have been probably now hundreds of
thousands
of cattle mutilations that have happened
over decades who's been caught
has a single person ever been caught
doing these surgeries on these animals
that's what i find most intriguing
hundreds of thousands of people
over sorry hundreds of thousands of
cattle
over decades not a single person
has even been a suspect
what does that mean you're out on
ranches the middle of nowhere
you can see lights from cars you have
people standing right there
i mean this has to add up to you
you have to understand that this is
abnormal
that this is something very strange that
it's a mystery
find me one person one that's ever been
caught for this
you won't because it hasn't happened is
there any relationship between aliens
and consciousness we mentioned remote
viewing
possible telepathy before yeah is it
possible that through psychedelics
altered states of consciousness one can
either evoke contact or possibly
communicate with them
and this we're getting off on a huge
speculative jump
but i'm a man of speculation i don't
mind
it's a fun topic let's talk about it i
mean you know uh you know it's reported
that people do i mean look
dudes do hallucinogenics and then and
then report back to me i don't i don't
know i don't know
you know i i've never experienced it so
i i don't know like are people
communicating with other things that
comes with a caveat just for the people
watching
jeremy's not endorsing that you take
just legally so that we can get that out
of the way well where it is legal you
should do it i am endorsing it
if you're if if it's legal where it
wasn't your apartment yeah yeah
no it's no problem i don't think they're
bad so you know here's the deal
uh i i think that there's an unexplored
territory there i think that
anything that alters your consciousness
if done responsibly
it can be very powerful and where it is
legal i think that's really cool
i think that shamans for you know
hundreds of thousands of years
have utilized um certain plants to
alter the state of human consciousness
to try to integrate into a
different consciousness i think it's
very silly
that we believe somehow collectively
that governments have the right
to tell you what you can do with your
own body like that's
um something that seems counterintuitive
to my way of thinking i i definitely
encourage people to
explore different states of of
consciousness because the base
consciousness we have
can be really limiting you know we live
sometimes in fear
we live sometimes in hunger we live
sometimes in
in all these things that if we can move
from that state
into a state of wonder and exploration
we're going to learn a lot more that's
where creativity comes from it comes
from these problems that we have
that we need to find a solution so
problem solution and change
so to answer their question i i really
don't know i i don't know
it is reported that the
non-human intelligence that appears to
be
operating or performing in the
in the form of ufos so operating ufos or
using
them as performance that this apparently
non-human intelligence
does engage with with humankind in in a
in a way that is i don't know what you'd
call it but a
consciousness driven so that is what's
reported
to me i have never experienced that
so i don't know but i would encourage
anybody
to try to explore the realms of
consciousness
in a safe way in a legal way all of that
and then report into us like let us know
we need
more psychonauts we need more explorers
of psychology and of consciousness we do
this question i asked to lou which comes
from lonesome
space cowboy i have only one question
pretty subjective but i'd like to hear
his take referring to you if the general
public knew and saw what you
know and have seen what would the world
look like for the next week after that
how would the public react
for the next week right so imagine if on
the news
people were able to see what you have
seen but you can't reveal right now but
they've seen it what would the public's
reaction be
over the course of the next week
i suspect the response would be varied
you know depends on what your
idea is of the universe you know what
what is your idea
where do you live what are you part of
what exists outside of you and
i imagine that we are adaptable
creatures we we
very quickly change and adapt i mean
i've had
from my experiences you know i've had
the hair raised up in my arms and
it's this feeling of like holy [ __ ] like
this is
this is serious but then i went and ate
dinner
so i don't know i think people are ready
for
a deeper truth i think people are ready
to engage the possibility
you know look at it look at it like we
used to believe
things that weren't true right so we
used to believe um
that the entire universe revolves around
the earth right and
and then you know we come to find out
it's it's much more dynamic than that
you know and so we have planets orbiting
stars and then we have
you know really we have galaxies kind of
orbiting each other i mean
we just we keep going out and seeing
this homogeneous
idea of ever expanding moving
in action and motion living universe
so what happens i think what happens is
people accept it and they go eat dinner
and maybe they reprioritize their lives
a little bit
organic vistas has a great question have
you seen a correlation in reports
with regards to the season so for
example in more temperate climates there
are
higher ufo activities of course that
needs to be conditioned upon the
population because in colder populations
are less
people so there should be less reporting
no i i see a correlation with
the the more that people look up the
more that they witness the ufo phenomena
this one comes from pete leros make sure
to run some
of mick west's videos by him now i'm not
going to
do so in real time people can and then
this person linked metabunk.org
so i'm curious as to what he has to say
about them and
well basically that i'm curious as to
what he has yeah look there's there's so
many so many uninformed people
that try to dissect and um
refine information to prove their own
bias and it's an unfortunate thing
because i mean
people could be great assets to the
study of truth
if it wasn't so obvious and clear
that um people are trying to fit
the nature of reality into
this very specific viewpoint that they
want
to have because it gives them like clout
or credibility by going against
the grain i get that it's fine everybody
can do
whatever they want but it's disingenuous
and i think that everybody is
realizing that there are actual experts
that we should be listening to
there are people that are experts that
we should
be listening to but you know they need
to speak up
right so it's important to question
things and to refine them
but it is absolutely disingenuous
to ignore
the bulk of data
to try to
just isolate something that can help you
prove your bias like that's
it's just i don't have time for it i
tried to work with people like that
tried to help tried to give information
it's just it's not worth our time
everybody needs to decide how they
spend their time you should be really
weary of people that are very obviously
just
trying to
influence your opinion towards a
predetermined goal
now there are experts there are people
that are just
really sharp and on their game and i
really hope that they start kind of
speaking
up more because we do have to separate
you know the true from the non-true
we that's so important and
and even conflicting views views that
are different from one another
that you know there's tension that's
where we really get down to the to the
bottom line and we figure out
you know what is going on but i would
just you know kind of guard yourself
it should be self-evident it should be
really obvious when people are trying to
um influence you to their own agenda
in a disingenuous way
okay this question comes from the moving
forest is jeremy corbell familiar with
salvador pius or pais yes
or the pays effect so number that's
number one from this person
okay so yeah everybody sends me this
every
week i get this you know these patents
from the navy and oh my gosh
and look at this and you know it's
electro gravitic or whatever the hell
they call it and like
you know oh it must be true because it's
a navy patent and they've had people say
oh it is true
okay look um if we had this technology
we would be using it
like if we had this technology you know
in the 40s
we would be using it any country that
had this technology
we would be using it um i personally am
very confident
with the understanding that we don't
have this technology will we one day
i really hope so but i think where the
real misunderstanding is
and this is important the systems
described in those
patents are from my understanding
like electro gravitic or they're they're
it's a completely
different process it doesn't negate
the distance dilemma and i really want
to push that out to you i haven't really
talked much about this
i'm i'm labeling it for you it's called
the distance dilemma okay
patents do not show a machine
that can do what we have been witnessing
for the last century for the last
thousand plus years
they just don't show that that's not the
mechanics
of the of the or the physics that is
described in those patents
it's a non-issue whether they have it or
not
which they don't or whether they have it
in some
rudimentary version maybe
it does not describe the physics that
people are seeing and observing through
the ufo phenomenon we are talking about
gravitational systems full stop
flat that's it that's what we are seeing
our military scientists that work in
exploitation projects they
know that they're not going to come out
and say that most likely
in the report that's coming out maybe
friday
but that is understood that is known and
just so happens to be exactly
the same type of technology that
bob lazar robert lazar talked to us
about
so look
i get it it's interesting you see these
patents uh where's the attack
is salvador still alive do you think
salvador will speak to me there's he or
she
i'm i'm not gonna put anything past you
i'm gonna say that you know
the will is the way man you know do your
best
all right i'm gonna try my hand at bob
lazar then
that's a heavy lift i will i will do
some
lifting okay let's see the moving force
says
is jeremy corbell familiar with the us
navy's tr-3b
i am familiar with what people call the
tr-3b
i i was actually kicked out of a car one
time because i was getting
driven to the airport by a military guy
and i was asking questions and it was
like a joke and they kicked me out of
the car i was asking about that
tr3b um look
it's nonsense what is it first of all
for those who don't know like myself so
so the tr-3b
is allegedly a perfectly
triangular craft that you know with
rounded edges
that works on positive lift in a way
that is unconventional so gravitational
in nature or you could say
electrogravitic i don't know depends on
on what people think
they're saying when they say tr3b we
have certainly tried
to work with different propulsion
systems however as you
see we are completely limited in the
united states military
in 99.9 percent
reactionary propulsion systems from
rockets
to roller skates you push something out
the back
you go forward that's it so the tr3b
has that you know one of the five
observables that lou elizondo talks
about
so when you talk about the tr3b you're
talking about something that has
positive lift
but from a non-reactionary propulsion
system so let's just say for
sake of argument some people think it's
a gravitic craft an
anti-gravity craft um it would actually
be a gravity craft
not an anti-gravity crap that's because
people don't understand what that means
right
it's not it's it's using uh
gravitational craft use sometimes
natural gravitational fields to operate
on but they also can
produce gravitational fields because
gravity is indeed a way
anyway check it out
no it's nonsense we are not seeing
terrestrially made tr-3b craft that our
government has produced
i'm sorry to burst the bubble i was sad
the day that i was
definitely you know i can stand behind
that as being the case
i would love to be wrong oh my gosh i
would love to be wrong
oh my that would be one of my greatest
days if i was wrong
uh but no i'm sorry uh we don't have
this technology
as far as our ability to create it
f is me in the live chat wants to know
why doesn't the government contact top
scientists to study the ufo
data radar etc in your opinion what if
scientists offered their help would that
help disclosure
right so why don't they contact the most
ego driven scientists that think
they should be contacted about it or why
don't they
contact scientists they
do this is what you saw with bob lazar
they they do this is what you see with
um
dr eric davis this is what you see with
dr column kelleher
they do these exploitation programs it's
just that they're so compartmentalized
there has to be people have to have
clearances and they have to be brought
in
and then they're trying to solve
problems and they can't talk about it so
the real problem is not that
scientists aren't contacted it's the
limitations of their ability to have
peer-reviewed information
to share data to have greater and other
minds on it
that is the problem look our government
has been trying to reverse engineer
non-terrestrial spacecraft that is a
fact we have craft you don't have to
believe me
listen to what harry reid said about
lockheed martin
having let's say hardware
you know think about what um in the new
york times what dr eric davis said about
off-world vehicles not made on earth
like
don't have to take my word for it like
just start understanding what's going on
we are having a sea change this is a
completely different world
that we are about to live in that we are
living in you know where the stigma of
ufos and talking about it
the reality of the presence of ufos on
planet earth
is being confirmed but as if you need it
confirmed but
have it confirmed by your government
great so this is a historic time
in human history this is not a foreign
adversarial nations technology
like china or russia this is not china
spends more money every year millions
and millions and millions hundreds of
millions of dollars
trying to steal our most rudimentary
technology
right they do not have these machines
that we've been seeing
for centuries and more they don't and
neither does russia and neither do we
in the sense of us being able to make
them but most countries
do have hardware that has been recovered
as is all i'll say because i don't know
exactly how to define it
right okay what's going on what do you
think is going to happen in the june
report i asked lou and he said a whole
lot of nothing
because it's not enough time but what do
you think
sure i mean it depends on what what you
want
like you know from lou's perspective i
can understand a whole lot of nothing
he's tempering expectation
however um i am fighting to have a
really robust report
until the penny drops right until it
comes out like anything's possible i
mean why do you think i'm
releasing what i know will be pentagon
confirmed videos in a big loud public
way
making sure they have the data so that
they can be responsible and beholden to
the american will on
some really good cases i'm doing this
with george knapp we're doing this
to try to create a more robust report so
you know i don't want to be cynical
about it you know look
if if what's said is that these are not
u.s black projects great like that's a
huge
deal to take that off the table then
we're gonna have to take off the table
you know other foreign
advanced technological nations because
these aren't them that's not what's
happening
but it's a step forward so i don't know
i'm just like an optimist dude
i just feel really good about it like
more information
makes our environment more data rich
than
no information so i'm sure people will
be disappointed oh my gosh the
bellyaching when you give
people a new piece of evidence the
bellyaching outweighs the gratitude and
that's maybe that's human nature maybe
that's because we're selfish maybe
that's because we're excited
it's okay i don't know but you know i'm
very um
just the fact the report exists that
these questions are being had this
conversation
is going on i am extremely motivated by
that
well you're a large part of as to why
it's happening so thank you man
charles wants to know please ask about
the department of energy
and the bureau of land management's
involvement they recovered a craft in
1945.
i've heard this uh i i think that it's
limiting
to say that there are specific
dod agencies or you know that are that
have a full grasp on all this
it is my personal experience that
every intelligence agency
and every branch of our military
has had does have
and has been running ufo
exploitation programs since as far
back as i know so look
there are certain agencies which have
more or less access to things that
utilize
different private industries to shield
information
from freedom of information act requests
so we see that with lockheed
they're shielding information using the
fact they can't be part of a freedom
of information act request but they're
doing it on the behest
of let's just say an agency at the
department of defense
so i would say let's look broader
because every single agency has a part
of the puzzle
let's bring it all together let's
encourage
that with encouraging ufo transparency
some agencies are better equipped than
others
to tackle certain elements for example
we know the defense intelligence agency
was well equipped through the funding
from
senator harry reid the 22 million
dollars black project money
for awesome advanced aerospace weapon
system applications program
that was to study ufos
and associated phenomenon where atip was
born
later from that and that was to focus on
military encounters
we need to divide and conquer so not one
agency not even the department of energy
which has been connected for a long time
to this
which tells you something but but look
in the name what does it tell us
well
department of energy what it tells us
is that the the power and propulsion of
these
vehicles of the ufo phenomenon the
associated
power and propulsion is important
that's what it tells us and let's just
stop it there and see what happens
sure this question comes from kd please
ask jeremy why true ufo insiders run
from the word demonic while discussing
ufos and instantly stop interviews
squirm and dodge the word
it's always jarring because these
insiders act like they have been given
some strict talking points to not use
that specific word i find it odd
i i don't relate to that i i don't know
uh
who she's talking about is there a
person that has dodged
that question um i would suspect if a
person dodged that question
uh maybe they have their own inherent
bias
that that is causing them to do that but
there's no script none of us were
given a script you know when we're
talking about ufos that we can't talk
about
the idea of you know demonic aspects
because that is something that
has been proposed even within the
military
circles because people have like a
fervent religious belief
like in the uh defense intelligence
agency that was something that really
was trying to
crush the program because the ufos
must be demonic they must be you know
something otherworldly in in that
spiritual realm
well come on that that's obviously
an individual's preconception and
worldview that is an influencing
policy and then stymieing the scientific
process
but but again i i don't know this is not
my i'm not a theologist i don't know
what you call him i'm not
i'm not in this realm so i don't know
but i don't think anybody is squirming
or running away from that if somebody
does it's probably just their own
personal viewpoint um look every option
is on the table until you can
you know until you can get rid of it
this question comes from rob
mcdonough does he think that there are
any pre-existing agreements or treaties
with the owners
of these uaps that are decades old 50s
to 70s
and are part of the reason that modern
that we exclude modern-day presidents
slash government from full disclosure
because power can change every 48 years
so basically is there some international
agreement or treatise
you know or an effort to study this i
look
i i don't know if there's an agreement
or something that would be
pretty cool right i'm i i don't know i
i do know that there have been attempts
by our military to communicate with the
operators or the yeah say the operators
of these craft whether they be
biological entities artificial
intelligence whether it be probes or
man craft i don't know
but but i know there have been attempts
to
bait and to lure the ufo phenomenon
so it can be better studied
scientifically and it's been very
interesting how one would do that
and i think it's best i i let other
people speak on that if they will in the
future
but that is something that is already
public that there have been attempts
to bait or to lure the other you know
phenomena so of course look
if it was up to me it would be um very
similar to
the movie close encounters where you
know there's some sort of communication
of course we might run into a problem
you know which is like the movie
prometheus
oh there you are earth right so that was
not a
great portrayal of the kind of
interaction you want to have but then
you have other
beautiful films because i'm a filmmaker
so i look at it this way
and they have movies like arrival and
there's this really
special uh dance that is done to
learn kind of how to communicate with
these other
entities you know i think all of it is
important it might turn out poorly it
might turn out well but i fear nothing i
think that if
they wanted to these visitors if they
for lack of a better term
uh these visitors like if they wanted to
harm us
you know they could and uh maybe they
would
have already i i just don't see that i
really don't see that
you know it does lead you to two kind of
um
difficult questions you know which is is
this just you know some sort of
beautiful slow process of indoctrination
to the existence of some other
life forms and intelligence or is it
because we're valuable to them like a
commodity
i mean i don't know i know that they do
interfere with nuclear weapons like
in many countries this is well
documented
shutting down nuclear weapons turning
them on displays of power
um they're very interested you know um
these vehicles
traverse through highly sensitive and
restricted airspace dealing with nuclear
weapons so
that should kind of give you a hint of
um
you know that there is extra activity
surrounding our nuclear
work and and that makes you wonder uh
why
speaking of the possibility of treating
us like commodities
i believe it was lazar who said that
they referred to us as containers or he
was referring to a document that he made
there we go let's be very precise
like so bob will tell you he'll be the
first to tell you because people always
say
[ __ ] he never said all he said was
i read in in in black and white pages
i read that i i don't know that to be
true
but that is one of the things that he
wrote he read a bunch of stuff
right right right yeah but but so so i
mean
we could philosophize about it you know
we could have like a fun
you know sci-fi kind of conversation
what what does that mean
you know containers of blood containers
of consciousness
containers of souls like what does that
mean are we like a fine wine
and we're being um kind of maturing in
our vessels until harvested i mean
that's a wild idea like i i have no idea
i have zero idea i'd like to think it's
probably more simple than that but
then again i'm a simple man so maybe i'm
wrong
victor wagg asks why does the flying
triangle ufo in corbell's research
sorry released footage flash at the ntsa
aircraft mandated rates for airliner
safety
well that's incorrect so um does it
flash
at that exact rate i mean i've got
varied reports if it does or doesn't
um maybe it does you know the answer is
i'm i don't know
you know if you look at the history of
ufos ufos are often
flashing they've actually used flashes
to
communicate this is something that's
historic
right so if it if it indeed is flashing
that one
and by the way these are pyramids
these are not out of focus
night vision and okay i'm sure that's
horrible
[ __ ] it's absolute fundamental [ __ ]
but but that's okay it's so easy
i just have to ask but it's it's because
but let me yeah let me let me kind of
explain
i kind of think we should unravel this a
little bit so
that footage is filmed on one of these
which is i have this is military issued
this is exactly what people get it has a
cap
the cap is right here it's got a perfect
circle right the the idea that like you
could make like
i could put a prosthetic suit on you
give you a
fabulous beard and you could look
exactly like me right
so i can take anything and make it look
like something else
um that's not occam's razor that's
mental gymnastics worthy of a gold medal
and this is where you see people trying
to influence
the thought process to go far outside of
the scope of the reasonable
to try to end somewhere that they feel
is reasonable
so i'm telling you so there is
corroborative evidence but it doesn't
matter what i say you have the united
states military investigating these
they have much better sensor systems
than what i could what i released was
non-classified
totally non-classified but they knew the
exact height of these craft
they knew the shape three-dimensionally
and if you look at the non-classified
yellow bar in that release of that
it wasn't a classified document but this
page was not classified
and you can read what they're saying
they're saying it appears triangular
due to all you know angle of observation
but but in fact their pyramid shape
so with that said i can make anything
look like anything else if given enough
time in metal gymnastics
um why is the craft blinking there
initially before i ever reported on this
took me a long
time to verify everything right like
right after the event basically but i
was able to verify over time and more
corroborative information came forward
and oh it's in the uap
task force reports okay so that's my
process
but when we get there it's like this
there are so many options like
the object itself could have been
blinking there's also a very specific
light on the uss
omaha that at that time i'm trying to
verify but was also blinking at that
exact rate that was just said to you
there also is a helo pad that's right
down so all of
right down on the ship and and that
could have had its warning lights on and
as a highly
what appears to be a reflective surface
because of the way that the night vision
shows
kind of the the glow reflective
so there are so many things that could
be accounting for that that i can't
narrow it down to
i know it's this i know it's that but
taking
one piece of information that is
ridiculous
and then trying to dismiss the entire
network of understanding of how that
video got to me what it says what the
pentagon says
what the briefing slides which the world
should never have seen but until i was
able to get it and put it out
you have to look at everything together
before closing your mind like a
triangular aperture what are jeremy's
thoughts on the fraver incident how did
the tic tac know where the predetermined
cat point was located
great question really interesting
question that comes from keith shoop
okay keith good question uh again sorry
i don't know but i you know i have some
ideas i can tell you what other people
thought so just for your audience we go
back to it so commander david fravor and
i were talking for
many many years before any of this came
out i promised him i wouldn't kind of
out him with this but i
did tell him one day it's gonna get out
one day it's gonna get out it's not
gonna be by my hand
because we didn't even know i didn't
even know if the videos i i've had that
video for a long time it was classified
right i didn't know
um and you know how commander faber
actually found out that he had been kind
of exposed to the public
i called him i told him i was like
hey man told you it was gonna happen it
happened it's out now
so permission to move forward you know
uh
there are some really important aspects
to his
case that are not widely reported or
picked up on by the public
the gentleman i think you said his name
was keith that just asked that question
is saying how did when the tic tac
object
shot off from commander favor at beyond
hypersonic speed
how did it then get like let's say 60
miles away
at his cap point which is an encrypted
location that he didn't even know at
that moment i don't believe it's a it's
a it's a location
that he's going to be going to whether
he knew about it or not
doesn't matter it's it's conveyed
through an encrypted system
so you can target the planes directly
where you want to go you can't just say
fly that way you'll find it right you
give them the exact location
how did the tic tac know we're assuming
that
whatever intelligence is operating the
tic tac that it did know and
that is a big assumption i mean it could
have been like the most amazing
coincidence of all time
i i believe it did have understanding
that it was toying with us
but now we're going to get into
something really weird right so
is this object able to know where it is
because it was able to decipher our
encrypted communications
how quickly did it get over there is
that the scan
of the spy 1 radar is it instantaneous
or did it take a second
to just show up so was it traveling from
point a to point b
really really fast or did it go from
from point a
to point b in a kind of stepped pattern
where it's moving through space time in
a so in a different kind of way than we
know
all of these all of these are big
questions that can be answered once we
understand the propulsion system which
again is gravitational so
the question here becomes did it was it
able to encrypt our technology
or due to the nature
of the propulsion system itself
was there a temporal effect
that allowed us to see it there
super quickly but in fact it was moving
through time space
differently than we know because of the
nature and effects of gravity
which is the type of propulsion that it
had and think about this when commander
fravor saw it
it was over the water moving like a
ping-pong ball in an empty glass
is that because it is moving that fast
or obviously
um in a way not because then the
inertial effects
it would explode it would just explode
but
it is negates the inertia effects
because of the propulsion system
so are we seeing a temporal uh
dislocation
because of our optics all of that so i
hope people kind of understood that i
hope that i'm saying in a way that's
kind of
simplified but full you know is that we
don't know if it shot there really fast
or if it temporarily stepped there
really quickly and then was picked up on
radar which would be then
a an effect of the gravitational system
what else is there about the favorite
case that you think should be talked
about more but
isn't what was under the water
what was under the water that's what
should be talked about more
anything else about the fravor case in
particular before i go to the next
question
yeah how long and how many contacts were
being seen
and being observed and being tracked and
at what trajectories
and what were they doing right so that
would be interesting
what were they doing what's under the
water there what were they doing
they weren't coming to display like like
around the uss omaha
uss russell nine warships july 15th
there's one major event in 2019
i released radar footage thermal footage
night vision footage and i'm about to
release something more okay
so that was a performance
these craft are trying to make
themselves seen
what was happening with the tic tac it
wasn't doing that
these tic tacs weren't doing that these
crap they were doing a job
what was the job these are questions i
think that we should um
philosophize more about we should try to
find more information about
what's coming you said that you have a
video coming out soon yeah pay attention
when
get ready two weeks get ready
paranoid android asks any connection
between the alleged archaeological
discovery of ufos and visits to
antarctica by
john kerry buzz aldrin and patriarch
krill in 2016. that would be outside of
the scope
of what i uh know to be true you know
this
is we're going deep into the mythology
of of ufos and
it could be true i i don't know uh this
is not my wheelhouse or my area of
expertise but i would uh not take
anything off the table
until you can dismiss it i'm sure you've
spoken to people who claim to have been
abducted do you see any commonality do
you
have a yeah you surmise a reason or an
intent behind the abductions
you know um
look where there's smoke there's fire
you know we know ufos are real now
okay so is what people have been saying
about them real
uh sometimes yes a lot of times
no so we have to kind of take everything
with like a
you have to like bring a whole bag of
salt not like a grain of salt you have
to
bring a whole bag of salt with you and
you have to make sure that uh
you understand the human nature of
consciousness and the idea
of how we try to assimilate really
intense experiences
into our functional daily life so we can
operate and eat our meal later tonight
um there is fire
to this abduction thing that there is
like there's something going on and and
there are
similarities and and uh very bizarre
strange little what similarities uh
well i'd like to keep some of that you
know private because it allows me to
to see if that's right it allows me if i
announce it then it becomes part of the
zeitgeist and then all of a sudden
people report that to me you know
so i'm gonna sorry but i'm you know you
can do your own work
you can do your own work and you can
find those things out and then you can
tell them publicly to anybody you want
but for me i have to hold some things
back like for example
in 1989 if how do you get to area 51 and
if you do get through a terminal
like if you go into your first building
what color is it painted inside that
room on the left-hand wall
like very specific questions right those
helped me to know if people are
bullshitting me
so that's kind of like i got to keep
some stuff to myself i don't know by the
way this is again not my total
wheelhouse i don't
i don't really know i'm kind of a nuts
and bolts kind of guy when it comes to
the ufo topic
but i i do believe there is something
really massive to the abduction
phenomenon and again most are bs
but but some are um genuine i i do
believe that to be true
what does that mean when you say you're
a nuts and bolts person with regard to
this phenomenon i've heard that
somewhere else maybe from you yeah
probably for me because i like to say
like i'm i'm nuts and bolts but my
family calls me [ __ ] nuts so i'm like
you know
maybe it's because of my background in
jiu-jitsu is i'm a very mechanically
oriented person like you don't sit there
and
argue with somebody in a jiu jitsu
grappling match like
i'm going to kick your ass no i'm going
to kick your ass you just
grapple and whoever has the dominant
day wins that's it and if you lose
it's because your technique was bad and
so you're sleeping
so with the ufo world
you know we can argue about things we
can talk about things all day long but
but ultimately ultimately
it's either true or it's not true so we
just have to get into the mechanics of
it
and try to understand if we have
corroborative censored data
if we have good intelligence if we have
reliable witnesses if there's inherent
bias
so so that's what i mean is that i try
to approach the study for me of the
mystery of ufos
from a very hands-on
boots on the ground gumshoe reporting
mechanical
type of philosophy but but
it's not um clinical you know i find
that that people
will open up if we can have a dialogue
where they don't feel
that you're going to dismiss them
because of what they experienced
have there been communications
intercepted between alien between
crafts or uaps ufos or have we
communicated with them
can we tap into the alien internet whoa
that would be really neat right can we
uh decipher code do we have messages
um i don't know i i know allegedly there
have been a lot of all you know
very interesting uh i
do know that ufos seem to
absorb data they seem to go over
sensitive installations
and use techniques to harvest
data which is very concerning to our
defense intelligence
sorry what do you mean by that how do
you know they're harvesting data just
because they're over it
right so i don't know they're harvesting
data just because they're over it this
is something that has been a real
concern
by the department of defense that it
appears
that when ufos come over certain
sensitive military installations such
as nuclear facilities that they have the
capability of shutting
off or turning on our nuclear armaments
one at a time so this tells them that
they have
an ability to exchange data between our
machines
and their craft or their will that then
tells us to do that you must have the
information
on one side to alter it so we know that
they are
absorbing certain amounts of data in
order to affect
the physical machinery that's what i
mean
this is something that's well
established
okay jeremy i know you got to get going
i i want to ask anyone one last big
question because then we gotta
i gotta get in later what questions
should we be asking as the public
that is a that is the best question
look at that that's the question i
always ask is what question am i not
asking you that's really important right
um look as the public
was said they wanted to ask the public
okay as the public every
single person should be asking the
questions that are burning with desire
within them
your passion your enthusiasm your desire
to understand the nature of reality is
going to drive
the ufo transparency movement it is you
not me that makes this happen right it's
not
one person who's on television this
is the average individual person that
wants to come forward with unique skill
sets
it's going to take philosophers and
scientists and activists and podcasters
it's going to take family conversations
about religions
this is going to be something that needs
to be addressed on
every single level of human existence
what questions should you be asking as
the public is
what questions you want answered because
you are driving this why do you think
the senate intelligence committee is
demanding information
from our intelligence agencies about
ufos it's because the public has
demanded it
it's not because one person went on
television and asked for it
so my answer to you is get involved i
like to say and people mock this all the
time but it's
i'm not backing down from it it's great
weaponize your curiosity
right the idea that you are not going to
be a passive consumer of this
information
absorbing information but you become an
active participant
in trying to discover the nature of
reality the nuances of this mystery
so in to kind of finalize and end this
really fun time with you and thank you
kurt
for what you're doing and thank you for
i didn't know i was going to do a live
ama that's great very cool i'm glad that
people are asking their questions and i
wish i could do more of these
but i'm too busy running for it on other
things right now
everybody needs to get involved
everybody
needs to do what they can do and do it
in any way that you think you are going
to be most
effective every question is good the
only bad question
is a question is a question that you
know the answer to or you're leading it
to be disingenuous and i see a lot of
that with debunkers it's
bs the best questions are the ones you
really want to know the answers to
so you know thank you so much for your
time for everybody that's watching now
you know thank you for your time i know
kurt's going to do a great job of
putting this together i wish i could do
more of these you know
and i'm sure i will but just this is
going to be a big time in human history
this is going to be a very important
next couple years
where we're looking at the subject and i
think very important next couple weeks
so uh you know get ready put on your
helmets not the tinfoil hats i'm saying
put on your helmets it's about to get
rough jeremy i'm honored i'm flattered
i'm i'm humbled by the fact that you
would spend some time with me thank you
so much
and the audiences as well we all have 24
hours in our day
we all choose how to spend it hopefully
for our lives
we spend our time well this was time
well spent so thank you very much
i'll talk to you later all right man and
if you can please send me that audio
recording once you're done just
shut off send it to me as soon as you
can thank you so much
take care we gotta go we can do this
again when you're let when you have less
of a hectic schedule
maybe we can sit down for a three-hour
joe rogan for our five-hour type
conversation
in person at some point i would like
yeah from now two years from now we'll
see
we'll see world is moving forward a
lot's about to happen
so we'll see we're going to be living in
a different world as what should i be
doing
okay so i'm a part of exactly what
you're doing exactly what your radical
is i'm not a theoretical physicist
but my background is in mathematical
physics you're a curious person it
doesn't matter what you are
you're curious you want to know about
the stuff keep asking questions
thank you my friend all right brother
talk to you soon okay
thank you all i'm just going to read
through some of the comments timothy
lacy yes your question i don't know what
your question was
so i apologize that i wasn't able to get
to it i'm seeing almost like
when you watch the matrix and there's so
much code on the screen right now the
chat
is just going forward so quickly that it
might as well be
gibberish if you're curious as to who's
coming up next on the podcast
this person named chris langan who has a
cognitive theoretic model of the
universe
it's one that it's an interesting one
based in not formal systems but it's a
meta language
that's a theory of everything remember
this channel is about theories of
everything
diana pasulka is coming up though that's
not scheduled eric weinstein's coming up
though that's not scheduled
again if you would like to see more
conversations like this
then please do consider going to
patreon.com there's a link here
donate a dollar donate 10 donate
whatever you like 50 cents
each one helps much more than you think
man thank you all i appreciate i didn't
even get to see how many people were
watching
again almost 3 000 people if not more
than 3 000 at its peak would be awesome
if i get sam harris says abg sam harris
i'll need a few months to prepare for
it's on the horizon what i mean by that
is that it's
it will happen at some point same with
jordan peterson
littlest spooky kurt do you feel jeremy
was lying during the interview
i didn't sense that i don't sense the
deceit that some people claim in him nor
lazar
doesn't mean that they're not
obfuscating or that they're not
misleading i don't sense it
i'm also i also tend to not like
questions like that because as i
mentioned
it's strange that this community who's
interested in aliens
alienate people for
believing in someone's scrupulous nature
or unscrupulous nature
i think that even if you think someone
has
even if you think someone's dishonest
well i just don't think there should be
they should be met with such
excoriation
do i have a degree in physics yes how do
they move so fast without sonic boom
this is a reason why i asked luis
elisando if when the craft went under
in a transmedia fashion to the water was
there
any trace of a splash because i want to
know if it's
shifting matter at all as it moves
the matter around the craft right
diggerdog said that the ufo community is
similar to the sasquatch community in
that way
see it's so funny because i'm an
outsider to this community i'm i
wouldn't
i don't consider myself a part of it
because i don't i know not almost
nothing if you watch jeremy riss's
interview of me
from alien scientist tv i pretty much
had my mouth shut
for 99 of it because there's so little
that i know
on this topic most of the time for
the podcasts on this channel i spend
weeks and weeks preparing
reading even going so far as to read the
papers by the
interviewees whereas and i'm well
informed but whereas for this topic
it's like i'm in real time being
educated i don't spend time researching
this
outside of the actual podcast i do a bit
of do a bit i prepare a modicum i would
say
compared to the physics
excuse me as i try to
hold on to my thoughts it's been it's
been quite a whirlwind lately i should
get some rest and eat
as well and spend some time with my wife
which i'm looking forward to doing
before i go there's a discord the link
to that
i'll put in the description of this
video if you like you can join the
discord and talk about this topic in the
discord there's a sub
server i believe it's called a ufo
server so you can talk about
ufos if that's what interests you i'm
mainly interested in what's called
theories of everything
okay have a great day everyone thank you
so much
you